nos dicen completa la tabla con números
enteros para escribir 10.74 en dos
formas diferentes pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo por su cuenta
piensen en qué es lo que pondrían aquí
para que esto sea una representación de
10.74 vamos a resolverlos juntos voy a
reescribir este número con más espacio
para poder inspeccionar los valores
posicional es una forma de pensar en
esto es que hay cero unidades hay una
decena pero en la tabla no lo expresan
de esta forma no está escrito como una
decena y cero unidades sino que dice
diez unidades lo que es razonable por lo
que en lugar de decir que hay una decena
en la tabla se refieren a esto como que
hay diez unidades o lo pueden ver como
una decena y cero unidades de cualquier
forma hay diez unidades y si nos movemos
una posición decimal hay siete décimas y
tiene sentido porque hay un siete en la
posición de las décimas después vemos
estas cuatro centésimas en la tabla lo
que también tiene sentido porque hay un
cuatro en la posición de la cnte
ahora analicemos esta parte de la tabla
nuevamente no indica una decena sino que
indica 10 unidades esto es lo mismo
podemos decir que hay una decena y 0
unidades o podemos decir que hay 10
unidades y en esta parte se redujo el
número de décimas y pueden preguntarse
qué es lo que está pasando aquí aquí
dice que hay 7 décimas pero una forma de
pensar en esto es que se reagrupa de una
posición a otra lo que hicieron es tomar
esa décima extra y la colocaron en otra
parte y el único otro lugar donde
pudieron colocarla es en la posición de
las centésimas si tomo una décima de la
posición de las décimas una décima es
igual a diez centésimas por lo que una
forma de pensar en esto es que tomaron
una décima de aquí por lo que ahora aquí
hay seis décimas y donde pondremos esa
décima pues se pone en la posición de
las centésimas y esa décima serán diez
centésimas si a las cuatro centésimas
que hay acá le sumamos diez centésimas
quedan catorce centésimas
por lo que escribimos 14 hagamos otro
ejemplo simplemente para asegurarnos de
que comprendemos lo que estamos haciendo
nuevamente nos dicen completa la tabla
con números enteros para escribir 5.4 en
tres formas diferentes pausa en el vídeo
y traten de resolver lo vamos a
reescribir este número 5.4 y en el
primer renglón está la manera estándar o
tradicional de interpretar 5.4 en la
posición de las unidades hay un 5 que
podemos ver aquí y en la posición de las
décimas hay un 4 que es lo que está en
la tabla cuatro décimas pero qué sucede
en el segundo renglón aquí dice 24
décimas
así que una forma de pensar en esto es
que de alguna forma pudieron tomar 20
décimas pasaron de 4 décimas a 24
décimas si sumamos 20 décimas aquí
entonces debimos tomar esas décimas de
alguna otra parte 20 décimas es lo mismo
que 2 unidades por lo que debieron tomar
dos unidades de las
unidades de acá si quitaron dos unidades
de 5 entonces quedan tres unidades
ponemos tres en esta sección de la tabla
pueden verificar esto 24 décimas es lo
mismo que dos enteros o dos unidades y
cuatro décimas o 2.4 y 2.43 es igual a
5.4 muy bien aquí abajo hay una unidad
que le pasó a las otras cuatro unidades
pues debieron ser transferidas a la
posición de las décimas vamos a
reescribir el número si quitamos cuatro
unidades de la posición de las unidades
queda uno qué pasará si transfiero esas
unidades a la posición de las décimas
pues habrá 40 décimas 4 unidades son 40
décimas por lo que sumamos 40 décimas a
las cuatro décimas que ya hay aquí ahora
quedan 44 décimas y terminamos